this is our segment of the week where we
call financial advice
for dummies
okay
there are certain things that are basic
one of the best things i ever did was
stock market investing for dummies
people who you calling a dummy you
calling dummy dumb you
yeah cause you don't know everything
that's true 75 of americans apparently
live in paycheck to paycheck i hear
other terms sometimes it's 65 75
right 50 of americans don't have 500
bucks for an emergency the average
american makes 40 50 grand a year
how are you paycheck to paycheck people
making 100k a year living paycheck page
40 of americans making a hundred grand a
year paycheck to paycheck 60
of millennials making 100 grand a year
live paycheck to paycheck you know what
they're called what's up henry's
high earners not rich yet oh you like
that henry
you didn't see that one coming you're
making money
um you're spending it all right any of
those facebook analysts henry's
100 something do you mean
i'm sure
let's ask exactly all right all right go
so financial advisor dummy so you're
familiar with reddit yes i love you you
love reddit what do you love about
reddit this uh the uh is it the front
page of the internet front page of the
internet that's right i think that's
their little slogan that's cool i like
it so anyways i i i watch reddit
sometimes but anyways there's a a money
page a money savvy page subreddit called
financial planning
right cool and they asked older people
to share their money advice to young gen
z's okay so hopefully they will take it
to heart and get better with their money
this is a buzzfeed article so here are
the top 12 top rated responses because
you know
with reddit you could what thumb up
thumb down what does it mean yeah your
thumb up and that's like liking it in
favor and then the more thumbs you get
it goes higher on the algorithm people
like it people like it people like it if
it goes down it goes down it goes down
read it all right so it's a cool page
called financial planning and here's
some of the older people's advice
what they want young people to know for
young gen z tell me old man tell me old
man
break it down for me old man
number one we say this all the time pay
yourself first pay yourself first
whether it's 10 15 20 designate a number
and bring that home for saving and
investing
sound advice sound advice we've heard it
a million times
but fifty percent of
um
money is your knowledge yes i know but
the other fifty percent is behavioral
are you actually doing it yes i know how
much if you ask someone how much money
should you bring home well ten percent
twenty percent are you doing it no no
not even close not even close i was at
the strip club no it's at the stream
club with gabby
no
designate them out and bring that home
every single month cool number two get a
budget together track your expenses and
your income and understand cash flow
don't
i
know it step one of your money's have a
game plan understand what's coming in
the door what's going out the door i
talk about offensive defense yeah how
much points you put on the board that's
your offense how many points are you
giving up a game that's your defense
we're talking about the phoenix suns in
the early 2000's steve nash mary
stodomer are these guys putting up 125
points a game most points in the league
the problem is they were giving up 126
and they lost they couldn't win playoff
games get it together have a budget cool
budgeting you know the only thing worse
than doing a budget every month what's
that not doing a budget every month
we gotcha
i gotcha
anyway have a budget understand your
cash flow what i call it is having a
game plan for your money number three
money doesn't buy happiness you but you
know what it buys
opportunities yeah opportunities to say
yes to something but also you know what
else opportunities stated no
say no to something hey we're going to
need you to come in and do this job and
i you know i'm good
i don't need the money that bad i'm okay
hey are you willing to um
like sometimes we'll need shooters yeah
you know i'm on the road traveling hey
we got to get a shooter what's our
budget 400 bucks all right but if you
can get them for like 200 bucks you get
over 200 bucks
you offer someone 200 i'm good i'm good
like i don't need the money all right
would you do it for 400 sure
if you have money saved up you have the
opportunity to say you've got the power
for the opportunity
that's like warren buffett said the
power of no yeah anyway moneybutt
doesn't buy happiness but it buys
opportunities what did kanye said having
money isn't everything
but not having it is he's oh lyrical
genius lyrical gene anyway
money doesn't necessarily buy happiness
but it buys the things
that can make you happy or opportunities
buys time buys buys
opportunity opportunity cost is what
they call it anyway number three money
buys happening this guy was angry he
says pay your dang student loans
and learn how repayment looks
there's a correlation between defaulting
and not paying your student loans and
anxiety that
i'm sure that's common for a lot of
people out there okay so student loans
the big deal
you know as a buying administration
taking away student loans ten thousand
dollars fifty thousand dollars what's
happening
i wouldn't bet on that i would bet on
you know there's forbearance are you
making your payments or you're not
certain federal loans are being exempt
from having to be paid certain
private loans not so much
david you got any student loans oh yeah
hell yeah i do oh god so is that why
you're making that face right there yeah
yeah your face don't look good right no
i don't man you bring up student loans i
get a little crinkle in my stomach yeah
oh man i know i got i can't i don't have
to pay them for the rest of this year
but look the average student loan takes
18 to 20 20 years to pay off
again this goes back to our initial
stories college worth it how much debt
you're making what's the roi the cost
benefit analysis this guy's angry says
pay your dang student loans bro
okay understand and just understand how
repayment looks it works you can't run
from it that's the one thing like you
can bank you can go bankruptcy you can
declare bankruptcy and get out of things
student loans not so much
number five open a credit card to start
building credit and pay it in full
every month to avoid interest don't i
know it i use credit cards i use a
credit card every month i pay it off i
remember being in my early 20s paying
minimums
interest started piling up not fun you
know the interest on credit cards on
average average interest on a credit
card david
um i don't know what's the 17 i was
going to say 15. okay all right 17.
let's just meet in the middle called 16.
okay so you think that's a good rate to
pay okay that's horrible
horrible
if you're going to invest and make money
you know a good return on your
investment good good 10 10
so you're willingly
you know
going backwards
anyway avoid paying interest and pay it
off in full every month absolutely
number six don't try to impress your
friends
or buy their approval keep it real like
getting
exactly papua new guinea we spent five
and a half million dollars on maseratis
to impress people not cool
um
definitely agree with that one don't try
to impress your friends or buy their
approval
they smell
they smell what's going on they say oh
they say your friends they smell fresh
they smell don't impress them reeks of
desperation look what i got yeah cool
bro thanks
um
here's this this is good for all the
people out there entering relationships
right there i see louis alpha going ham
yeah on the board on the chat see what
he's got going on right there
if you're getting into a relationship
right find someone with similar
financial goals
the power of two incomes and saving
together is really powerful that
is for sure i've been in relationships
where basically the girl was not
interested in working we're not
interested in making money had me pay
for everything
it was taxing
not cool i've been in a relationship
where it's like let's grind let's do
this thing together let's make some
money let's it's a different feeling so
i totally agree with that advice
if you're getting into a relationship
find someone with similar goals the
power of two incomes and saving together
is really powerful
respect number eight understand roth
iras 401ks and david david's favorite
thing
index fund those are cornerstones in
wealth building and ps
if you've got a 401k and your company
gives a match that's free money three
months go take that money talk about
saving that money and talk about saving
that money to invest that money
but there's nothing better than free
money there's nothing better than free
money if your company is willing to
match your 401k and give you five
percent or whatever you're
you're um contributing go take that
money that's like walking over money on
the side of the street like now i'm good
go get that money go get that match
there it is
accompanied with that a company with
your 401k and your roth ira and your
beautiful index fund
to build wealth you know what else you
know what you know the cornerstone
within that what's that compound
interest the power of compound interest
what's that guy's name what guy albert
einstein uh-huh alfred einstein out
albert is it albert or alfred it's
albert okay good just double checking
making sure i got your sauce
albert einstein said
alfred
compound interest the eighth wonder of
the world those that understand it earn
it those that under don't understand it
pay it did he really say that yeah holy
hell there it is there it is albert
einstein he called it the eighth wonder
of the world the power of compound
interest the key to investing time and
compound interest that's it two
ingredients
okay number ten
increase your earnings
aka get a better job
learn a new skill make smart career risk
is it worth it is it not worth it should
i make more money is it worth it getting
that job i don't know if i dig this job
i'll make more money but in the long run
i won't be as good if i take this job
i'll you know maybe short term i won't
make as much money but long term there's
major upside there i can get equity in
the company my sales okay cool you got
to calculate those risks
makes sense earn more calculate the
risks make sense
okay
number 11
save dollars
spend pennies
basically they know the difference in
dollars and pennies so what i talk about
within your budget everyone has the same
big three expenses
your housing your rent whatever your
mortgage yeah your transportation your
car how you're getting around right and
number three your food and beverage how
much you're spending each month to eat
and to drink those are your big three
expenses yeah i'm not worried about the
little things the little things
all right the phone bill the light bill
i mean those are things those are things
those are the big three things in your
budget
okay there's a big difference like okay
i could i could spend two grand on rent
or i can spend 1500 on rent okay cool
all right well if i do the 1500 thing or
if i get a roommate i only spend a
thousand and then i split the rent okay
now i'm saving five ten thousand dollars
a year okay cool
or i get the two thousand all right so
that's down on that versus i don't know
should i get the
app on my phone that's
5.99 a month okay cool that's 60 bucks
70 bucks a year whatever
the big stuff is what they're talking
about right count dollars not pennies
okay so and also when it comes to like
when you get your tax return and you get
a couple thousand bucks you get a
stimulus check and you get a couple
thousand bucks right those are a lot
things that you need to be clear
decisions on yeah versus like a coupon
going to the shopping plaza and whether
you get you know a box of this or a box
of that for four dollars versus 350.
minor stuff right pay attention to the
big stuff
save dollars spend pennies cool and
finally here's a big one here's a big
one ooh okay write this down people
this is for the people that are like i
don't know man things are tough things
are tough i can't figure out how to save
i can't figure the best i can't figure
out my job
this actually this is some more
emotional advice it finally says don't
lose hope
i know it's not practical
in the sense of dollars and cents like i
was mentioning how it is however
essential to take
those first few steps to get the ball
rolling toward a brighter financial
future don't i know it
younger generations are in dire
financial straits and i fear they will
adopt a sort of financial fatalism
that will delay or even kill any sort of
financial planning don't give up it's
never too late to start if you know they
say the best day to plant the tree was
20 years ago the next best day is today
okay if you have nothing saved start
saving you haven't started investing yet
start investing right don't give up okay
a lot of people watching this are 20 30
years old what have you
don't give up yeah don't ever give up
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken